si vous tenez vous prêts en seconde
partie de l'émission vous allez
découvrir quelle était la position des
étoiles des étoiles à votre naissance
d'ailleurs que c'est difficile
sans se faire des nœuds au cerveau oui
je m'en suis mis pour écrire le
conducteur Michel je vais vous sauter
une nouvelle fois pour aller vers Jeff
vous trouvez pas cavalier c'est parce
que vous avez déjà le chrono d'or mais
je vous avais bien compris
personne ne saute personne Valérie vous
avez sauvé des libido en même temps que
vous avez refait des décos ah bah oui
parce que nous les couples c'était
vraiment ils vivaient dans des chambres
qui n'existaient pas en fait avec des
décos ou tu ne peux pas te retrouver en
amoureux dans ce genre de chambre donc
c'est vrai que les parents souvent nous
demandaient des chambres un peu cosy un
peu tout ça j'étais là voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'est un jouet que j'ai eu avec moi
toute ma vie
[Rires]
c'est une référence à
la Pologne en 2014 ils avaient sur le
plateau c'est quelqu'un qui battait
références à d'anciennes prestation
[Applaudissements]
tous les mots d'amour que je sème tu ne
les entends pas et je vais bloquer ces
paroles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était la blague de Nagui qui me fait
pleurer
contrairement aux apparences l'Europe et
l'Ukraine ne sont pas encore mariés
alors en recevant la présidente de la
Commission européenne volodi mirzelenski
lui a réclamé des négociations
d'adhésion pour que l'embrassage ne soit
pas que de façade
[Musique]
volodièreski était à Rome aujourd'hui
pour rencontrer son homologue italien
Sergio matarella la chef du gouvernement
Giorgia Meloni mais surtout pour un
entretien avec le Pape François le
président ukrainien a été reçu Vatican
il en a profité pour remettre au
Souverain Pontife un gilet pare-bal
porté par un soldat ukrainien et sur
lequel a été pas ensuite une
représentation de la Vierge Marie
ça fait 5 saisons que j'attende d'être
transféré à The Voice j'ai l'impression
que ça va pas arriver finalement mais
bon en tout cas j'ai vous dire un truc
je suis bien content de vous avoir et je
suis content de vous avoir tous les cas
je suis
contentes
toute la soirée
[Rires]
[Musique]
il enlève les touches superposées
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui accusent le groupe France Télé de
concurrence déloyale alors elles ont
adressé à la première ministre Elisabeth
borne une lettre pour dénoncer je les
cite une programmation étonnamment
commerciale sur les chaînes de France
Télévisions en gros pas assez de culture
des spectacles vivants trop de polars
trop de divertissement qu'est-ce que
vous leur répondez Michel Field
par chiffre parce que factuellement leur
lettre est un tissu d'inexactitude et
d'approximation
[Musique]
aujourd'hui un soir sur deux ou sur
trois TF1 est battu par France 2 et TF1
ne supporte pas l'idée de voir s'appeler
TF2 c'est grâce à la c'est grâce au
travail d'un homme sur la fiction c'est
et moi je dis vraiment s'ils aiment tant
l'opéra et le théâtre nos amis Nicolas
taverno et Rodolphe
mais oui qu'ils en mettent sur leurs
antennes
[Applaudissements]
au nom de victoire
Lorraine devient la deuxième artiste
ayant remporté deux fois l'Eurovision
login 1987
je suis tellement heureuse pleine de
gratitude une victoire saluée et fêtée
par des Suédois qui attendaient
l'événement depuis des années
on a gagné
Laurine est incroyable elle m'a donné la
chair de poule je suis trop émue
loin derrière à la 16e place grosse
déception hier soir pour Lazare l'année
prochaine c'est les 50 ans
la Suède et on mangera des rollmops ça
vous ira si je suis toujours là
est-ce que tu veux faire un bisou à
quelqu'un en regardant la caméra
non tu sais pas